Ucrania es algo así como el Julen Lopetegui
de los países: últimamente, sólo da malas
noticias. En las últimas décadas, Ucrania
ha sido el escenario del peor accidente nuclear
de la historia, un conflicto armado y todos
los escándalos de corrupción que os podáis
imaginar.
Es más, los políticos ucranianos tienen
otra cosa en común con Lopetegui: también
tienen los bolsillos repletos de dinero. Tras
la caída de la Unión Soviética, la economía
pasó de manos del estado a manos de los amigos
del estado.
Ahí tenemos a SERHI TIHIPKO, por ejemplo,
banquero y ex vicepresidente. O a YULIA TIMOSHENKO,
ex presidenta del Ucrania y conocida como
la princesa del gas. Por no hablar de PETRO
POROSHENKO, actual presidente y dueño de
la principal empresa de chocolate del país.
En otras palabras, que todo cambió, para
que no cambiara nada.
Es más, es AHORA cuando empezamos a ver cambios
en Ucrania. Pero… no son cambios a mejor.
Todo lo contrario.
Veréis, en el anterior vídeo de esta serie,
os contábamos cómo Rusia es el principal
proveedor de gas de Europa. Por ejemplo, Alemania
compra el 60% de su gas natural a empresas
rusas como GAZPROM o ROSNEFT ¿Y por dónde
viene todo ese gas? Pues casi todo viene por
los gasoductos que cruzan Ucrania.
¿Y todo esto qué significa? Pues que, aunque
Ucrania apenas tenga recursos de gas, es un
país clave en este negocio. Y sí, aquí
es cuando entra en escena nuestro querido
amigo, el único, el ínclito… VLADIMIR
PUTIN!
A día de hoy, Putin necesita a Ucrania para
poder suministrar de gas a Europa. Y, como
ya sabéis, las relaciones entre Moscú y
Kiev están ahora mismo en “es complicado”.
Como dirían Les Luthiers, el amor eterno
dura, aproximadamente, 10 años. Así después
de décadas de amor y fraternidad eslava,
el Gobierno de Poroshenko quiere alejarse
todo lo que puede del Kremlin.
Como os podéis imaginar, este divorcio político
no le hace la más mínima gracia a Rusia.
Cada vez que su gas cruza el territorio ucraniano,
tiene que pagar un peaje millonario a su exmujer
¡Pero no sólo eso! Mientras Ucrania está
en el centro de la ruta del gas, el Gobierno
de Kiev tiene una baza para poder negociar
con Rusia o con la Unión Europea. Dicho de
otra forma, a día de hoy, la importancia
de Ucrania a nivel internacional reside en
que les necesitamos para poder tener gas.
Así que ¿Cuál es la estrategia de Putin?
Pues… esta
Los rusos insisten en un Nuevo gasoducto para
sortear Ucrania y a los europeos les parece
bien
Sí, amigos de VisualPolitik, la estrategia
de Rusia consiste en aislar a Ucrania en las
rutas del gas. De este modo, Ucrania perdería
todo su interés estratégico. Esto significa
que ni la Unión Europea ni Estados Unidos
moverían un dedo para defenderlos ante una
nueva y posible invasión rusa.
Así que la pregunta es… ¿Realmente puede
funcionar esta estrategia para aislar a Ucrania?
¿De verdad Europa va a permitir que Ucrania
se quede a la intemperie? Hoy vamos a responder
a estas preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un
poco de historia.
SI NO ERES MÍA, NO SERÁS DE NADIE
En el año 2000, el 70% del gas que llegaba
a Europa venía a través de Ucrania. Más
concretamente por el llamado gasoducto BROTHERHOOD.
Esta tubería se construyó en tiempos de
la Unión Soviética y su importancia creció
a medida que crecía la demanda de gas. El
otro 30% viene por el gasoducto Yamal, en
Bielorrusia. Pero eso es otra historia.
En el momento en el que se desintegra la Unión
Soviética, Ucrania se convierte en un país
independiente. Y es en ese momento cuando
en Kiev empiezan a ver el Business. Si Rusia
tiene las reservas de gas en Siberia y está
usando mi territorio para llegar con su tubería
a Baviera, estoy tardando en exigirles un
peaje.
Ahora mismo, ese peaje son más de 2000 millones
de dólares anuales pero ha llegado a ser
mucho más en el pasado. Gracias a esos llamados
“derechos de tránsito”, la compañía
estatal de gas ucraniano, Naftogaz, se convirtió
en una de las más grandes del país. Y todo
esto, pese a que en Ucrania casi no hay yacimientos.
Pero como os podéis imaginar, esto es mucho
más que economía. Tanto en Rusia como en
Ucrania, todo es susceptible de ser convertido
en un arma política. Así que, cuando Kiev
tenía un gobierno prorruso, GAZPROM dejaba
el gas a precio de amigo. Pero en el momento
en el que Kiev dejó de tener un gobierno
prorruso, los precios se dispararon.
Ya lo contamos en el primer vídeo de esta
serie: las negociaciones a cara de perro entre
Rusia y Ucrania llevaron a los ucranianos
a quedarse sin gas en 2006 y 2009. Y en este
último corte, el de 2009, también se quedó
sin gas toda Europa.
Y ahí es cuando Rusia aprovechó la coyuntura.
Putin llamó por teléfono al excanciller
alemán y actual presidente de ROSNEFT, Gerhard
Schroeder. Y Gerhard Schroeder llamó a la
actual cancillar alemana, Ángela Merkel.
Así es como se vendió el primer proyecto
para evitar a Ucrania en los envíos de gas:
el gasoducto Nord Stream 1, que pasa por debajo
del mar Báltico.
Poco después, en el año 2010, Yanukovich
ganó la presidencia de Ucrania. Yanukovich
es prorruso, así que la calma y los precios
bajos volvieron. Pero en 2014 tuvimos el Euromaidan.
Meses de protestas que se llevaron por delante
a Yanukovich y que trajeron a un nuevo gobierno
totalmente antirruso. Y en ese momento es
cuando Putin dijo “si no eres mía, no serás
de nadie”.
Desde 2015, GAZPROM, que es la principal gasística
rusa, comienza el plan definitivo para sortear
a Ucrania de una vez por todas. Por un lado,
comienza la construcción del NORDSTREAM 2
por el báltico. Por el otro lado, en el sur,
Gazprom ya está trabajando en el TURKSTREAM
que va por el mar negro. Según el presidente
de Gazprom, en el año 2020, ese gasoducto
Brotherhood del que hablábamos antes, transportará
sólo un 10% del gas que bombea ahora.
Pero esperad un momento, porque dicho así,
parece que los rusos son muy malos y los ucranianos
unos pobres desamparados. Para nada, ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver.
EL GIGANTE UCRANIANO
Naftogaz es mucho más que una compañía
de gas. ¡Es una oficina de empleo! Tienen
nada menos que 175.000 empleados. Para que
os hagáis una idea, su homóloga en Polonia,
PGNIG, que también es estatal, sólo tiene
25.000.
En otras palabras, que en Ucrania te miran
mal si no tienes un cuñado trabajando en
Naftogaz. Creo que hasta Lopetegui les ha
enviado su curriculum a ver si cuela.
Como os podéis imaginar, Naftogaz es un auténtico
agujero negro en las finanzas de Ucrania ¡Pero
no sólo eso! Su mayor problema es que cuando
los contratos van pasando por tantas manos
en una empresa estatal, se van cayendo los
millones. Según un think tank de Kiev que
se llama el Institute for Economic Research
and Policy Consulting, la corrupción en NAFTOGAZ
supone más de 3.000 millones de dólares
al año. Hablamos de una empresa que sistemáticamente
da pérdidas. Para que os hagáis una idea,
las pérdidas de 2014 llegaban a ser un 6%
de todo el PIB de Ucrania.
Pero justo en ese año, en 2014, surgió el
Euromaidan. Y en Ucrania se sucedieron cambios
muy rápidos. Cambios como este.
“La policía ucraniana detiene a Yevhen
Bakulin, consejero delegado de Naftogaz”
El nuevo CEO de la empresa es este señor
que veis aquí, ANDRIY KOBOLYEV, uno consultor
que por entonces no tenía ni 40 años. El
trabajo de Kobolyev se podría resumir en
dos objetivos: acabar con la corrupción y
acabar con la dependencia de Rusia.
Y no creáis que hablamos de palabras vacías.
Tanto la Unión Europea como el FMI han presionado
a Ucrania para que haga sus deberes, y eso
explica cosas como esta.
“Gas Storage Europe anuncia nuevas mejoras
de la iniciativa de transparencia del almacenamiento
con la unión de Naftogaz de Ucrania al inventario
de almacenamiento de gas (AGSI +)”
Desde entonces, Naftogaz ha empezado a dar
beneficios por primera vez en décadas. De
hecho, ha dejado de ser un agujero en el presupuesto
para aportar al Estado el 13% de sus ingresos.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Cómo lo ha hecho Kobolyev?
Pues como suele pasar con los monopolios estatales,
el gas era tan barato que los ucranianos tenían
puesta la calefacción hasta en agosto. Natfogaz
ha subido el precio que pagan los consumidores
poniéndolo al un nivel parecido al del resto
de Europa.
Por el otro, Koboliev le ha plantado cara
a Putin con, lo que podríamos llamar, pensamiento
lateral. Veréis, Gazprom quería subir el
precio del gas a Ucrania… pero no al resto
de países europeos. Así que ¿Qué ha hecho
Naftogaz? Pues recomprar el gas ruso a otros
países como Eslovaquia.
Los contratos con Gazprom establecen que cuando
el gas llega a un país de la Unión Europea,
Rusia pierde el control sobre el gas y el
país en cuestión puede hacer lo que quiera
con él. Por ejemplo, el gas llega a Eslovaquia
a través del gasoducto Brotherhood y después,
vuelve por el mismo camino a Ucrania. De esta
forma, Naftogaz ha reducido el coste de importar
gas a una cuarta parte.
¡Pero esto es sólo el principio! Koboliev
sigue buscando alternativas ¿Por ejemplo?
Azerbaiyán. Como ya hemos explicado en otros
vídeos, Azerbaiyán está construyendo el
gasoducto TRANS ANATOLIAN, que llega hasta
Italia. Pues bien, Kiev quiere poderse enchufar
a esta tubería a través de Bulgaria. Y sí,
ya sé lo que estáis pensando, en toda esta
historia del gas ruso, el más claro ganador
es Azerbaiyán pero de eso hablaremos en el
siguiente vídeo. Por cierto, que si no os
lo queréis perder, ya sabéis, suscribíos
a VisualPolitik y dadle a la campanita.
En fin, que por el momento parece que Ucrania
está limpiando la corrupción ¿Verdad? Pues…
esperad un momento porque, como siempre decimos
aquí, no todo es tan bonito. Para que Ucrania
se pudiera adaptar del todo a Europa, tendría
que liberalizar su mercado del gas. Es decir,
que Naftogas perdiera su condición de monopolio
y se pudiera dividir en varias empresas: una
dedicada a la producción de gas, otra dedicada
al suministro… en fin, una empresa independiente
para cada actividad. Y aquí es donde llegan
los problemas.
“La Unión Europea y Ucrania, en un tira
y afloja sobre la división de Naftogaz”
Como os podéis imaginar, por mucho que Koboliev
quiera limpiar la empresa, hay demasiados
oligarcas que llevan décadas viviendo muy
bien. Sí, la empresa puede ser todo lo estatal
que queráis, pero eso no quita que no haya
mucha gente cobrando sueldos millonarios y
llevándose mordidas muy, pero que muy, jugosas.
Y eso es casi imposible de erradicar de un
día para otro.
¡Pero esto no es lo peor! Veréis. en marzo
de 2019, Ucrania volverá a tener elecciones.
Y el resultado va a ser decisivo para el futuro
de Naftogaz. Y, mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
Rusia tiene ya una hoja de ruta bien marcada.
Ahora mismo la vamos a ver.
COMPETITIVIDAD VERSUS GEOPOLÍTICA
Alemania ya lo ha dejado claro: van a construir
el gasoducto Nord Stream 2. Tanto Bruselas
como Washington están en contra de este proyecto.
De hecho, las críticas más duras son las
de Donald Trump, que ya ha dicho que hasta
Lopetegui podría diseñar mejor la estrategia
energética de Alemania.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Cómo es posible que
Ángela Merkel se haya dejado seducir por
Vladimir Putin? Sí, vale, el otro día os
decíamos que el excanciller alemán, Gerhard
Schroeder, es el hombre Putin en Europa. Pero
hay mucho más que eso.
Básicamente: Alemania tiene un dilema de
los gordos. Por un lado, su industria necesita
gas. MUCHO gas. Cuanto más barato y seguro,
mejor. Y, si dejamos la geopolítica a un
lado y nos centramos en la economía, el Nord
Stream 2 es la mejor opción. Primero porque
es barato. Segundo porque evita todos los
problemas que conlleva el tránsito por Ucrania.
¿Cuál es el problema? Pues que ese gasoducto
va a hacer que Alemania dependa aún más
de Rusia.
Mientras tanto, Putin está encantado de la
vida. No sólo puede aislar a Ucrania del
tránsito de gas sino que también puede ahogarla
económicamente. En este sentido, las intenciones
del Kremlin son más obvias que cuando tu
exnovia te llama para “tomar un café”
¡Y no sólo hablamos del gas! Por ejemplo,
mirad este mapa…
Esto es el mar Negro. Ucrania tiene dos puertos
importantes aquí y aquí. Pues bien Rusia
ha construido un puente justo aquí, en Crimea
¿Qué consiguen con este puente? Pues que
muchos barcos no puedan cruzar el estrecho.
Y os preguntaréis… pero ¿Por qué Rusia
quiere arruinar a Ucrania? Pues… muy sencillo…
cuanto peor le vaya al gobierno antirruso
de Kiev, más facilidades tendrán los candidatos
prorrusos.
Y diréis ¿Pero hay algún candidato prorruso
con posibilidad de ganar las elecciones de
2019? Y la respuesta es que todo es posible
en Ucrania.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en este país
tienen una serie de TV muy conocida. Se llama
“El sirviente público” (“servant of
the people”). El protagonista es un profesor
que lucha contra la corrupción. Pues bien,
ya se ha registrado un partido político con
el nombre de la serie y donde el candidato
es el actor protagonista, que se llama Vladimir
Zelensky ¿Tiene posiblidades? Pues… no
os lo cuento, miradlo vosotros mismos…
“Tymoshenko, líder en la encuesta de candidatos
presidenciales, seguida por Poroshenko, Zelensky
y Hrytsenko”
Habéis oído, está en el tercer puesto,
detrás de la princesa del gas y el rey del
chocolate. Vamos, que es casi imposible predecir
lo que va a pasar… Sólo hay una cosa clara
en esta historia. Un actor que, a todas luces,
sale ganando de todo esto y ese es Azerbaiyán.
Pero de eso hablaremos en el siguiente vídeo.
Mientras tanto, la pregunta es para vosotros
¿Qué haríais si fuerais Alemania? ¿Aceptaríais
el gas barato de Rusia a cambio de dejar a
Ucrania sola… o sacrificaríais la competitividad
por las intereses políticos? Podéis dejarme
la respuesta en los comentarios.
Mientras tanto, si os ha gustado este vídeo,
suscribíos a VisualPolitik, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta
pronto.
¿Pensáis que Rusia busca hacerse con otras
zonas de Ucrania? Podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios.
Y, por supuesto, no olvidéis visitar nuestra
página de Patreon, donde tendréis acceso
a contenido exclusivo. Por cierto, suscribíos
al canal de YouTube para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones y si os ha gustado
este vídeo, dadle a LIKE. Nos vemos en el
próximo. ¡Un abrazo y hasta pronto!